Speaker 1: Congresswoman Nancy Pelosi will no
longer be in leadership. She is currently the
speaker of the House. That speakership is set to
end when Republicans take control of the House in
January of 2023. And Nancy Pelosi announced
on the floor of the House yesterday she is
not going to be seeking a leadership role, but
she will be staying in Congress. The Associated
Press reporting that this is a, quote, pivotal
realignment making way for a new generation of
leaders. Nancy Pelosi gave a speech. She said
that, first of all, she has led Democrats for
nearly 20 years. Secondly, she is dealing with the
aftermath of this brutal attack on her husband,
Paul Pelosi, last month in their San Francisco
home. She was the first female speaker of the
House and she will not seek any leadership role
starting in January. She says We must move boldly
into the future. I will not seek reelection
to Democratic leadership in the next Congress
for me. The hour has come for a new generation
to lead the Democratic caucus that I so deeply
respect. She received a standing ovation and
it is not typical that a party leader stays on
after withdrawing from the leadership. She was
reelected and there is much speculation about
whether this will be her final two year term.
She is 82 years old. We don't know the answer
to that. But Nancy Pelosi made it clear and it is
horrifying when you are influenced in your plans
by such a horrifying attack, like what happened
to Paul Pelosi, because to some degree,
you feel as though you're I'm letting them push
me out. But there were already questions about
Nancy Pelosi's future. Whatever you think about
her politics and I am to Nancy Pelosi's left,
you have to recognize not only the significance
as the first female speaker of the House,
but her 20 year tenure in Democratic leadership
and her ability to get things done there. Not
necessarily the most exciting things, always.
They're not necessarily the things I would
prioritize. But she did understand how the
House of Representatives worked. And while I
have taken issue with Nancy Pelosi so many times
on specifics, quite a career. Quite a career. So
Nancy Pelosi, stepping down from leadership,
will stay in the House of Representatives